HOIST THE CUP AND THE QUEST
STARTS TONIGHT FORTHER REBOUND M
BARBASHEV
A STICK UNDERNEATH FOR SURE, BUT
OBVIOUSLY THE R ST. LOUIS.
SCHENN.
AND HE THE ST. LOUIS IT,
ZUCCARELLO, KAPRIZOV DEFLECTING
INTO THE
THAT.
AND MAKE ZONE, THIS WILL BE
ICING AGAINST ST. LOUIS ASERYBOY
FROM HIM, A MIX UP FOR MINNESOTS
, 0-3 LEDDY.
THE BLUES WERE VERY GOOD THIS
SEASON, OUTSCORING OPPONEN THE .
MATT DUMBA.
THE FITH IT IN THE
CORNER TRYING TO GO TO THE LINE.
YOU CAN SEE THE POWER PLAY
GOALTENDING.
KAPRIZOV ALONG HOLD IT AND IT
IS HIM THEY
LOVE TO ROOF TA.
IT'S DEFLECTED IN, FULLY TO MOV.
SPURGEON.
A REDIRECT.ODIN, BACK DOWN LOW,G
>> THE ST. LOUIS BLUES
AND O'REILLY, CUT OFF BY
RIGHT.
AND PERRON IS HAVING HIMSELF ONE
E
VERYNG PASS, SAVED
BY MARC-ANDRE
REACT TO IT.PERHAPS A FITTING FE
HERE IN